Now, if you want me to have a.
To. To have a take on the American Congress and Senate,
I think I should not go there.
Because let's say that the American politics nowadays
is not at its best.
But one thing I can say,
I had the privilege to be prime minister
for being a NATO
when the former president was.
Was there. And despite the rhetoric,
despite the colorful way to confront adversaries,
I don't see that NATO was weakened.
On the contrary,
what was decided before
continue to be the case.
Every country continue to.
To put more money
and to put more effort in increasing the NATO budget.
So now elections are elections.
Trump is Trump.
American politics.
But I think United States is something more than that.